Pero conforme mi abuelo cavaba en el suelo del bosque,
Yo quedé fascinada por las raíces,
luego supe que debajo de eso había micelio blanco
y debajo, los horizontes minerales rojos y amarillos.
Finalmente, el abuelo y yo rescatamos al pobre perro,
pero fue en ese momento que me di cuenta
de que esa paleta de raíces y tierra
era la verdadera base del bosque.
Quería saber más,
así que estudié silvicultura.
Pronto me encontré trabajando con gente poderosa
a cargo de la explotación comercial.
La extención de la tala de claros
era alarmante,
y me sentí en conflicto por mi participación en ello.
No sólo eso, el corte y rociado de herbicida a álamos abedules
para abrirle espacio a pinos y abetos, comercialmente más valiosos,
fue impactante.
Parecía que nada detendría a la implacable máquina industrial.
Así que volví a la escuela,
y estudié mi otro mundo.
Verán, los científicos acaban de descubrir en un laboratorio, in vitro,
que la raíz de una plántula de pino
puede transmitir carbono a otra plántula.
Pero esto fue en un laboratorio,
y me pregunté si esto podría ocurrir también en bosques.
Yo pensé que sí.
Los árboles en los bosques pueden también compartir información bajo tierra.
pero era muy controvertido,
y algunos pensaron que estaba loca.
Me fue muy difícil conseguir financiamiento para investigar.
Pero persistí,
y finalmente realicé algunos experimentos en lo profundo del bosque,
hace 25 años.
Cultivé 80 replicas de tres especies:
abedul, abeto de Douglas y cedro rojo occidental.
Supuse que el abedul y el abeto estarían conectados por una red bajo tierra,
pero no con el cedro.
Estaba en su propio mundo.
Reuní mi equipo,
y no tenía dinero así que lo hice barato.
Fui al Canadian Tire
(Risas)
y compre bolsas de plástico, cinta plateada y tela parasol,
un cronómetro, un traje de papel, un respirador.
Luego tomé de la universidad algunos aparatos de alta tecnología:
un medidor Geiger, contador de centelleos, espectrómetro de masa, microscopios.
Luego conseguí algunas cosas peligrosas:
jeringas llenas de dióxido de carbono, carbono-14 radioactivo
y algunas botellas a alta presión
de un isótopo estable de dióxido de carbono, carbono-13.
Pero tenía permiso legal.
(Risas)
Y me olvidaba de algunas cosas,
cosas importantes: repelente de insectos,
repelente para osos y los filtros de mi respirador
¡Cielos!
El primer día del experimento llegamos al lugar
y una osa gris y su osezno nos persiguieron.
No tenía repelente para osos.
Pero así es como se investiga en Canadá.
(Risas)
Volví al día siguiente,
mamá oso y su osezno se habían ido.
Esta vez sí pudimos iniciar,
saqué mi traje de papel,
me coloqué el respirador
y luego
puse las bolsas de plástico sobre mis árboles.
Tomé mis jeringas gigantes
e inyecté las bolsas
con el isótopo rastreador radioactivo de carbono,
Primero el abedul.
Inyecté carbono-14, el gas radiactivo,
dentro de la bolsa del abedul.
Luego al abeto,
Inyecté el isótopo estable de dióxido de carbono, carbono-13
Usé dos isótopos,
porque me preguntaba
si había comunicación de dos vías entre estas especies.
Llegué a la última bolsa,
la número 80,
y de pronto la mamá osa apareció de nuevo.
Me empezó a perseguir.
Puse las jeringas sobre la cabeza,
estaba matando moscos y salté a la camioneta,P
y pensé,
"Por eso la gente investiga en laboratorios."
(Risas)
Esperé una hora.
Supuse que tomaría ese tiempo
que absorbieran el CO2 a través de la fotosíntesis,
lo transformaran en azúcar y lo enviaran a las raíces,
y quizá, supuse,
trasladarlo bajo tierra hasta sus vecinos.
Luego de esa hora,
bajé la ventanilla,
para ubicar a mamá osa.
Bien, estaba por allá comiendo arándanos.
Me bajé de la camioneta y me puse a trabajar.
Fui a mi primera bolsa con el abedul. Quité la bolsa.
Coloqué mi medidor Geiger sobre sus hojas.
Kshh!
Perfecto.
El abedul había absorbido el gas radioactivo.
Luego el momento de la verdad.
Fui hacia el abeto.
Quité la bolsa.
Coloqué mi Geiger, las agujas subieron,
y escuché el sonido más bello.
¡Kshh!
Era el sonido de un abedul hablando con un abeto,
y el abedul decía, "Oye ¿te ayudo?"
y el abeto decía, "Sí, ¿me mandarías un poco de tu carbono?
porque alguien me bloqueó el sol."
Fui hacia el cedro, coloqué mi Geiger sobre sus hojas,
y tal como lo sospeché,
silencio.
El cedro estaba en su mundo.
No estaba conectado en la red que conectaba al abedul y al abeto.
Me emocioné mucho,
Corrí por cada uno de los lotes y revisé cada una de las réplicas.
La evidencia era clara.
El C-13 y el C-14 me mostraban
que el abedul y el cedro tenían una conversación de dos vías.
Resulta que en esa época del año,
en verano,
el abedul enviaba más carbono al abeto, que el abeto al abedul,
especialmente cuando el abeto estaba cubierto.
En experimentos posteriores ocurría lo contrario,
el abeto enviaba más carbono al abedul que el abedul al abeto,
porque el abeto aún crecía y el abedul ya no tenía hojas.
Resulta que ambas especies son interdependientes,
como el ying y el yang.
En ese momento todo cobró sentido.
Sabía que había encontrado algo grande,
que cambiaría la forma en que vemos la interacción de los árboles del bosque,
no sólo como competidores
sino como cooperadores.
He hallado evidencia sólida
de esta red de comunicación bajo tierra,
el otro mundo.
En verdad creía y esperaba
que mi descubrimiento cambiara la práctica silvicola,
de clareos y uso de herbicidas
a métodos más holísticos y sustentables,
métodos más baratos y prácticos.
¿En qué pensaba?
Volveré a eso.
¿Cómo se hace ciencia en sistemas complejos como los bosques?
Como científicos del bosque, debemos investigar en los bosques,
y eso es difícil, como ya les mostré.
Además, hay que ser muy buenos para huir de los osos.
Y más importante, persistir
a pesar de tener tanto en contra.
Debíamos seguir nuestra intuición y experiencia
y hacer muy buenas preguntas.
Luego debíamos recabar los datos y verificarlos.
Yo he realizado y publicado cientos de experimentos en el bosque.
Algunas de mis plantaciones experimentales tienen más de 30 años.
Las pueden verificar.
Así funciona la ciencia del bosque.
Ahora quiero hablar de ciencia.
¿Cómo se comunicaban el abedul y el abeto?
Resulta que no sólo hablaban en el idioma del carbono
sino en nitrógeno y fósforo
y agua y en signos defensivos, en alelos químicos y horomonas..
información.
Debo decirles que antes que yo, los científicos ya pensaban
que esta simbiosis mutualista bajo tierra llamada micorriza
estaba involucrada.
Micorriza literalmente significa "raíz de hongo".
Pueden ver sus órganos reproductivos al caminar por el bosque.
Son los hongos.
Sin embargo, los hongos son sólo la punta del iceberg,
porque fuera de esos tallos están las redes de hongos que forman el micelio,
y el micelio infecta y coloniza las raíces
de todos los árboles y plantas.
Donde las células fúngicas interactúan con las células raíz,
hay un intercambio de carbono por nutrientes,
y el hongo obtiene esos nutrientes al crecer en la tierra
y recubrir cada partícula de tierra.
Esta red es tan densa que puede haber cientos de kilometros de micelio
bajo una sola pisada.
No sólo eso, el micelio conecta a diferentes individuos en el bosque,
no sólo de la misma especie sino entre especies como el abeto y el abedul,
y funciona como el internet.
Verán, como en todas las redes,
las redes de micorriza tienen nodos y enlaces.
Hicimos este mapa al examinar secuencias cortas de ADN
de cada árbol y hongo en un área del bosque de abeto.
En esta foto, los círculos representan los abetos, o los nodos,
y las líneas representan la interconexión de autopistas de hongos, o enlaces.
Los mayores y más oscuros son los nodos más transitados.
A estos los llamamos árboles núcleo,
o más cariñoso, árboles madre,
porque estos árboles núcleo nutren a los jóvenes,
los que crecen en el sotobosque.
Y si ven esos puntos amarillos,
son las plántulas que se han establecido en la red
de los árboles madre más viejos.
En un solo bosque, un árbol madre puede estar conectado a cientos de árboles.
Utilizando nuestros rastreadores isotópicos,
descubrimos que los árboles madre
envían el exceso de carbono a través de la red micorrizal
a las plántulas del sotobosque,
y lo hemos asociado con una sobrevivencia de plántulas
cuatro veces mayor.
Todos sabemos que favorecemos a nuestros propios hijos,
y me pregunté, si el cedro podría reconocer a su propia especie,
como mamá osa y su osezno.
Así que iniciamos un experimento,
cultivamos árboles madre con plántulas familiares y ajenas.
Resulta que sí reconocen a sus parientes.
Los árboles madre colonizan sus plántulas con redes micorrizales más grandes.
Les envían más carbono bajo tierra.
Incluso reducen la competencia de sus propias raíces
para crearle un marco a sus hijos.
Cuando los árboles madre están heridos o muriendo,
también envían mensajes de sabiduría a la siguiente generación de plántulas.
Así que usamos el rastreo isotópico
para rastrear el movimiento del carbono de algún árbol madre herido
desde el tronco hacia la red micorrizal,
y hasta las plántulas vecinas,
no sólo carbono sino señales de defensa.
Estos dos compuestos
incrementaron la resistencia de las plántulas a la tensión futura.
Así que los árboles hablan.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
A través de muchas conversaciones,
aumentan la resistencia de toda la comunidad.
Quizá les recuerde nuestras propias comunidades sociales,
y nuestras famílias,
bueno, algunas.
(Risas)
Volvamos al punto inicial.
Los bosques no son sólo un conjunto de árboles,
son sistemas con núcleos y redes
que se traslapan, conectan árboles y les permiten comunicarse,
y abren caminos para la retroaliemtación y la adaptación,
esto fortalece los bosques.
Esto es porque hay muchos árboles núcleo y muchas redes superpuestas.
Pero también son vulnerables,
no sólo a perturbaciones naturales
como escarabajos de la corteza que suelen atacar árboles viejos
sino a la tala intensiva y tala de clareo.
Verán, podemos quitar uno o dos árboles núcleo,
pero hay un punto crítico,
porque los árboles núcleo son como remaches de avión.
Puedes quitar uno o dos y el avión aún vuela,
pero si quitan muchos,
o incluso ese único que sostiene las alas,
el sistema entero colapsa.
¿Cómo perciben ahora a los bosques? ¿Diferente?
(Audiencia) Sí.
Bien.
Me alegra.
Recuerden que ya antes dije que esperaba que mi investigación,
mis descubrimientos, cambiaran nuestra práctica silvícola.
Bien, fui a revisar 30 años después aquí en el oeste de Canadá.
Son como 100 kilómetros al oeste de aquí,
en el límite del Parque Nacional de Banff.
Hay muchos clareos.
No es naturaleza virgen.
En 2014 el Instituto de Recursos Mundiales reportó que Canadá en la última década
ha tenido más perturbación forestal que cualquier país del mundo,
y seguro pensaron que era Brasil.
En Canadá, es 3.6% cada año.
Según mi estimación, eso es cerca de 4 veces el índice sustentable.
Perturbaciones masivas a esta escala afectan los ciclos hidrológicos,
degradan la vida salvaje del habitat,
y emiten gases invernadero a la atmósfera,
lo que genera más perturbaciones y muerte de árboles.
No sólo eso, seguimos plantando una o dos especies
y eliminamos álamos y abedules.
A estos bosques simplificados les falta complejidad,
y son muy vulnerables a infecciones y plagas.
Y conforme el clima cambia,
estamos creando la tormenta perfecta
para eventos extremos, como el brote de escarabajos en los pinos de la montaña
que barrieron con todo en Norte América,
o ese mega incendio en Alberta de los últimos 2 meses.
Así que volviendo a mi pregunta final:
en vez de debilitar nuestros bosques,
¿Cómo podemos fortalecerlos para lidiar con el cambio climático?
Lo bueno de los bosques como sistemas complejos
es que tienen una enorme capacidad de autoregeneración.
En experimentos recientes,
hayamos que con tala selectiva y retención de árboles núcleo
y regeneración de una diversidad de especies, genes y genotipos;
estas redes micorrizales, se recuperan muy rápido.
Con esto en mente, quiero dejarles 4 soluciones simples.
No podemos engañarnos con que esto es muy complicado.
Primero, tenemos que salir a los bosques.
Tenemos que involucrarnos localmente con nuestros bosques.
Hoy la mayoría de nuestros bosques
se manejan con un enfoque unilateral,
pero el buen manejo del bosque requiere conocimiento de las condiciones locales.
Segundo, debemos salvar nuestros bosques maduros,
que son los depósitos genéticos, de árboles madre y redes micorrizales.
Eso significa, menos tala.
No digo no talar, sino talar menos.
Tercero, cuando se tale,
hay que rescatar el legado,
los árboles madre y las redes,
la madera y los genes,
para que transmitan su sabiduría a la siguiente generación de árboles
para que resistan las tensiones futuras.
Necesitamos ser conservacionistas.
Cuarto y último,
debemos regenerar nuestros bosques con diversidad de especies,
genotipos y estructuras
plantando y permitiendo la regeneración natural.
Debemos darle a la Naturaleza las herramientas que necesita
para usar su inteligencia autocurativa.
Recordemos que los bosques no son un conjunto de árboles
compitiendo entre sí,
son altamente cooperadores.
Volviendo a Jigs.
La caída de Jigs me mostró este otro mundo,
y cambió mi visión de los bosques.
Espero hoy haber modificado su visión de los bosques.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)